[Music]
and spider-woman news in a melon
submarine submitted by race me Bart in
the car on the feets a 37 year old is
China's one and only Spider Woman in a
group of spider-man what this is a weird
[ __ ] why do I picture like all these
spider men like cosplay guys no see I'm
picturing somebody laying in like a tub
and having spiders crawl over them and
they like that [ __ ] oh look at she's
like it's like a fear factor thing mmm
that's what I'm picturing no what are
you guys I'm confused yeah I picture
like a shitty like Hollywood Boulevard
kind of touristy cosplay kind of stuff
like their spider-man but there's
actually a Spider Woman or they like to
dress up as real spiders has anyone done
that the superhero I want the actual bug
yeah there's this place in southwest
China where the Southwest these people
called the meow oh it could be male I
mean by the time you get there that they
might have their own like pronunciation
and dialect and everything different
culture me yeah what a city or province
it is in China yes in China and China's
Guangzhou province it's south of it it
says it's southwest China but south of
Guangzhou province it just says you know
the story me in southwest China I don't
know but that's a big that's a big-ass
pot it's a big-ass province and it's a
point of reference for me because that's
like the Texas of China
it's like close to Hong Kong it's like
the biggest and that's what the
Cantonese came from from going from
Bonzo so Miao is the biggest because the
people
oh so mal is like next to that's PI like
New Mexico or Colorado or something okay
right on what's your white people there
huh yeah
people traditionally only male men were
considered
men were considered real spiders clothes
so they were considered Raven filled
enough to become spider-man they call me
spider-man so these these men they would
climb are they infringing on Marvel's
copyrights or is it their own spider-man
oh well it's China so they definitely
definitely definitely take the copyright
yeah yeah they wouldn't climb these
cliffs that looked pretty intense I'm
gonna show you guys a video and you guys
can see it for yourselves they would
hang coffins from the cliffside and that
was like traditionally what they would
do but then over time they stopped doing
that tradition and now they just climb
to find plants for medicinal purposes we
can't grow those plants at the bottom
there's like special plants that are
growing on the cliffs
I don't know that only in China though I
feel like nobody's ever like you have to
climb the mountain to get the special
plan like in Colorado where there's tons
of mountains yeah it's always China like
it's about luck right or it's like it's
a special plant that only grows by this
waterfall where you have to risk your
[ __ ] life to get it I mean Chinese
people do that for all was it like
sparrows nests or like this person yeah
the birds nests it's in a cave where
it's in this high point in the cave it
is like what human being like went into
this [ __ ] deepest cave and how to get
20 ladders to go up to this bucking
birds nests take out the bird's nest
boil that [ __ ] and eat it what's the
point purpose of a Sparrow's egg it's
it's a bird's nest it's it's this nest
that you could only find in a cave and
it's it's a real expensive yeah it's
very good so anyways here's a jello I
love that you will you birds but you
Oneko come and I didn't like it all
right
bird spit and I liked it fun boiled this
region of Guangzhou China is famous for
its sprawling mountains rivers and
massive caves it's here that a
little-known ancient Miao tradition of
cave based rock climbing is carried on
by a few locals
known as spider-man
yeah burial tradition faded into
obscurity
and was a unique method of collecting
rare medicinal herbs that some say
remedy diseases such as asthma and
rheumatism the spider men with their
unparalleled climbing skills are the
only people who can get them woman the
only woman I mean wait why can't they
got those plants right why can't they
ribéry that mother [ __ ] way up next in
our house and grow more of it maybe it
has to grow in a certain like call me
yeah yes there's a lot of like what do
you call it like it can't grow here but
it can grow yeah altitude restrictions
or something maybe
so it says wow thank you
I hope so she's me she ain't gonna get
butthurt about it she's the [ __ ]
Mulan of climbing dude yeah she's the
first and only Spider Woman that did she
have to be pretend to be a man to prove
that she could do maybe the villagers
were like you wanna calmly out yeah
finally a girl wanna join us
no traditionally it was only men but
then like slowly that tradition started
dying out and there was less and less
people that wanted to become spider-man
so then her dad is a very skilled
spider-man man and so when she was 15
years old that's when her dad finally
allowed her or cuz she really wanted to
learn so then when she was 15 she
started climbing now she's 37 she's buff
for 37 that should look scary though
like a man or woman or whatever like for
me I'm just like just see them do that
with no ropes and five dude because
there's no turning back
you can't go I'm tired and then you just
use the rope to repel back Shh it's like
[ __ ] alright I gotta go up or down and
to me going down is scarier than going
up yeah her dad said like you know you
could climb up you've got a realize you
also have to climb back down it's
dangerous
I went bouldering and in like I made it
to the top and I was like yes but I was
so scared to climb down that I just let
go what's a call it's like rock climbing
without the rope yeah but it's indoor oh
okay
yeah there's padding so then I just got
up and I got to the top and I was like
yeah I know this chick has more balls
than any of us yeah at one point she
left her village to go work at a
construction site she's like [ __ ] that
out of there clam
yeah but then she went back to her
village in year 2000 she married a
villager and she had children and in
order to support her husband who drives
freight trucks as a for living she
decided to climb the cliffs to search
medicinal plant to sell and then finally
in 2015 the local government decided to
promote the mountain as a tourist
attraction and so they started hiring
Spider Men and as well as her to
practice their skills for entertainment
purposes oh that's dull yeah all they do
is climb every day for work she works
from 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. every day for a
monthly salary of 3,000 yuan or 458
dollars well a bunch of weird ass
Americans like take pictures of them
like look honey like somebody in a fanny
pack next to one of these people like
you know what they kind of remind me of
those mountain goats or whatever that
they're like the edge of the [ __ ]
cliff they look like they're stuck with
blue or whatever I know that [ __ ]
doesn't even look real that's why I
think we're in a computer simulation
yeah like cool when I see something like
that I'm like that's just hilarious
there's no there's no purpose of this
they're like hanging on an inch a little
- yeah they're not afraid of heights
kind of wanted this necklace looks
beautiful
it doesn't really be no it looks
gorgeous and the water is bright blue
can you go in water I bet there's her
there yeah if you can't down
I like corner tropical places I don't
want going places where he can't go in
water
[Laughter]
I gotta go to the hotter places ya know
when I was a kid I was so pissed cuz I
was on my uncle's boat and we were like
you know [ __ ] in the middle of like
the Chesapeake in Virginia or whatever
yeah we couldn't go in the water because
like it's polluted whatever whatever
reason no you can't go in the water and
I was like never going anywhere but I
can't go any why don't ya like it's like
let's go to Alaska I'm like nom Joe you
know the only travel to places like
Beach places is this news like big news
because it's kind of like they didn't
let Girls Aloud but now they let girls
allow its girl it's a girl power store
because I'm just amazed by anyone being
able to climb yeah for sure but it kind
of sucks that they had to make it a
gender thing and it's like yeah guys did
it all the time but this girl she's
doing it like I think well just amazing
to see that people climbing in the first
place yeah but I mean upper-body
strength for women is like really hard
to find I think and then hand strength
for women [ __ ] grip strength that's
what I was thinking as like her grip
streak nothing [ __ ] crazy yeah she
probably calluses according to feminist
twitter that's all in your head and
that's something that we all put in your
head because you are as strong as a man
but society tells you that you're not
okay when I do chesty I hate test day
like I just I just don't like doing
upper body yeah hearing you say chest is
funny to me just when I got a new chest
day we're gonna do testing then I mean
it's not it's not a fun ride what are
you working on day no but like don't you
work out you test when you work out your
arms no not everything I don't know I
don't know anything
why are you doing just anyways yeah want
you do interested oh and what are goals
though what you trying to do I'm just
trying to be like a cheese well you
aren't shape so what are you turn where
you turn
I want to stay in shape thank you
just what exercise everything and then
like even fleeting like warm days like
like buys and tries oh my god triceps
are the worst but your sister tell me
about it
look we're all drinking wine right now
like I'm bitching about MANET he's
talking about a workout routine hey guys
I hope you enjoyed that episode of just
kidding News and if you did really enjoy
it or if you have thoughts about what
you just watched leave a comment down
below and let us know and for the next
video click right up here
[Applause]
[Music]